senators have just started reading the
FBI report on allegations of sexual
misconduct against Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh Republicans and
Democrats will take turns viewing the
single copy of the document ahead of a
vote to cut off debate on the cabin on
nomination tomorrow a final vote could
happen as early as Saturday the Wall
Street Journal reports White House
officials read the FBI report and found
no corroboration of the allegations the
FBI interviewed about seven people
including friends of Cavanaugh and
Friends of Christine Blasi Ford who
claims Kavanaugh sexually assaulted her
in high school
agents also spoke to deborah ramirez who
alleges Kavanaugh exposed himself to her
at a party during their time at Yale
University they did not interview Blasi
Ford or Cavanaugh who denies all the
allegations more than 1,000 law school
professors have signed in New York Times
op-ed this morning saying the Senate
should not confirm Cavanaugh they say he
displayed a quote lack of judicial
temperament during his hearing last week
CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend was homeland
security advisor to President George W
Bush she served in his administration
with judge Kavanaugh and signed a letter
supporting his nomination before the
misconduct allegations were made public
friend good morning good morning give us
some sense of what these senators are
looking at is a binder is it transcripts
what are they looking at so the when the
FBI does an interview they do a record
of that interview called a 302 that's
the number of the form right and what
that is is a summary it's not a
transcript it's a summary of the
questions they asked and then the
witnesses answers and then that's all
collated into the background report
which is more likely a narrative that
pulls all those 302s together it may
also include the underlying three or two
reports why didn't they interview
Kavanaugh and Ford Enterprise by that I
am look I don't I personally don't
believe as a prosecutor that you could
have a credible and complete
investigation without an interview of
dr. Ford now I think what you're gonna
hear from the FBI is that they were
constrained in who they could talk to
you by the scope of the investigation
but even if you take that on face value
that they were constrained to
investigate the allegations of sexual
assault that still doesn't explain why
you don't interview dr. Ford but they're
saying they already have her testimony
and they already have his two
domani is that fair well that is fair
but what do you not get out of that well
you don't get out of that the therapist
notes which you could have asked her for
permission to get you don't get the
polygraph or the polygraph report which
you could have asked her for and so
there are a lot of good reasons in a
thorough investigation as a prosecutor I
think I would have sent the agents back
out to do that is it hurt the FBI was
credibility I think it does I think look
everybody called for this because they
were an independent third party they
were the gold standard in terms of an
investigation nonpartisan and to have
them now say we found no support for dr.
Ford's allegations but we didn't speak
to her I think does undermine their
credit but our background checks
investigations are they inquiries well
they're inquiries right and you're quite
right does they make the expectation
that all of a sudden that this was going
to exonerate someone or condemn someone
someone was wrong from the beginning
they gather information that's right and
they have no subpoena power they can't
compel anyone to test you to be
interviewed by them and I do think we
have to be you know from the beginning I
said you know what do we expect of the
FBI this allegation is 36 years old
they're unlikely I thought from the
beginning to be able to corroborate it
but they you know they also haven't
disproven it and said a lot of people
friend are raising questions now about
his temperament and if former classmates
are coming forward saying he actually
lied about his beat his behavior when it
comes to drinking does that matter well
I think it matters in the overall
consideration for the Senators but let's
be clear on this inquiry as an arroyo
was saying that was not part of it well
the FBI was asked to do was look at the
sexual assault allegations and so they
the White House cleverly sort of scoped
this back this additional background
investigation to exclude those things
that drinking his testimony under oath
all those sort of looking as a
journalist who you want to be able to
we're not gonna see this but I'm saying
for a senator you want to hear from as
many people as you can hear from so that
you can get a sense of who's believable
who's credible whatever why did they
didn't need to turn it in this earlier
they had some extra time why not just
interview a few more people that's right
and look the real question here is you
know from your time in Washington is
what is what is senators Flake Collins
and Murkowski think of this does that do
they think it's adequate and frankly I
don't think you've done very much to
give them much political cover because
it
not been that widespread so today's
today we want to watch those three and
that's the interesting point is whether
if seen people are saying this isn't the
scope isn't big enough whether they have
the political coverage the point that's
an interesting thing that Fran always
good to have you thanks